everywhere we look in the universe we
see the same stuff following the same
rules the universe is only made up of a
handful of basic ingredients hydrogen
helium lithium carbon and so on all of
these chemicals in different proportions
are what make us up and these same
chemicals in different proportions make
up
everything the same chemicals that form
galaxies and stars do something amazing
on
Earth perhaps even
unique they become living things
organisms that can grow reproduce and
think we are bits of the universe made
conscious I think that's a it's it's a
biological Miracle you look out into the
sky and you know you're connected to
that somehow it's pretty
fantastic so so when does the story of
life on earth
begin actually it begins long before
earth
existed after the big bang the universe
is little more than a vast cloud of
hydrogen
gas then pockets of the gas cloud
collapse to form stars and only Stars
can turn hydrogen into the more complex
molecules that will become planets and
people I don't think there's any way you
could make life out of just hydrogen you
need other compounds to give you the
more complex
chemistry the start of life was really
the start of the first Stars probably
about half a billion years after the big
bang deep inside the cores of these
early Stars heat and pressure crush
hydrogen atoms together so powerfully
they fuse creating helium atoms and
releasing a burst of
energy over time helium atoms fuse
together too creating carbon nitrogen
oxygen and even heavier
atoms over hundreds of millions of years
ancient Stars build up all the elements
that make up our solar system today
including the atoms in your body
but in doing so these Stars pay a
catastrophic price drained of energy the
ancient Stars collapse and then explode
in a supernova spreading their
chemically Rich Stardust across
space the iron in your blood the calcium
in your teeth and your bones these were
created in a supernova explosion
probably different stars that blew up
billions of years ago seeding the space
surround them with this
stuff we are the product of not just one
Stellar explosion but many Stellar
explosions and the atoms in our left
hand probably came from a different star
than our right hand the carbon nitrogen
oxygen iron all of that was only created
in stars and the only way I could get
here on Earth is if those Stars exploded
and that material was later Amalgamated
in our solar
system blasted through space these
complex atoms now pepper the clouds of
gas that are nurseries of new
stars and 4.6 billion years ago one
particular Cloud begins to collapse
under its own gravity and our sun
ignites much of the ancient stard dust
is sucked into the Sun never to be seen
again but the leftovers Clump together
to form comets asteroids planets and
eventually
life I actually think of myself as a
very complicated Rock I am made of
things like iron and copper and
manganese when you sit down on a
mountain side and you're there with a
rock those are your cousins
too thanks to ancient supernovas the
Earth forms with all the atoms needed to
create both rocks and life but what is
it that distinguishes us from a piece of
granite
there are essentially three main parts
to a living
organism you've got to have some
metabolism or some kind of system of
chemical reactions that powers your
life you've got to have some kind of bag
or sack that walls you off your internal
systems from the outside
environment and thirdly you've got to
store some kind of blueprint some kind
of description of yourself
three things a power source a protective
sack and the plans for making more
protected power
sources DNA is the plant it's a long
molecule built up from small units
called
nucleotides DNA contains the
instructions for how to build the cell's
protein engine using small molecules
called amino acids DNA also tells the
cell how to make lipids a fatty molecule
that forms a perfect protective sack and
that's all there is to it you have the
basic form of life a
cell the chemistry set for life is
actually quite simple it's 20 amino
acids it's a few nucleotide bases for be
making DNA and RNA a few lipids and
that's
it think of it as like a Lego
kit so where did this simple kit for all
living things come
[Music]
from in the 1950s chemist Stanley Miller
set up an experiment to find
out he filled a series of flasks with
water vapor and Volcanic gases to
recreate the early atmosphere of the
earth then he sent an electric spark
across the mixture to simulate
lightning the result a foul smelling
Gunk that included one of the three
basic building blocks for
life we find produced in this experiment
some amino acids some of the same amino
acids that are produced in life before
Miller's experiment it was assumed that
this kind of organic material could only
be produced by biology which is why it
was called organic Miller showed that
it's not biological it's occurring we
would expect lots of different
[Music]
places because amino acids were so easy
to make scientists wondered whether
these same molecules could have formed
in the gas cloud that made the
sun before the Earth was
born if the theory was right then
asteroids the leftovers from this period
of Planet building might still contain
these ancient MO ules
today this question was answered in the
1960s when a space Rock older than the
earth fell on meren
Australia when you pick up pieces of
this meite it it just reeks it stinks of
kind of organic volatile chemicals and
when you analyze what's in there we find
those plenty of amino acids that the
building blocks of proteins we find kind
kind of fatty molecules that make these
envelopes these membranes around all of
our cells and Incredibly we find the
bases of
DNA the merchon meteorite proved that
the component parts of a living cell are
everywhere they're in the mix when the
earth
forms the atmosphere of the early Earth
makes more and organic building blocks
continue to rain down for millions of
years after the crust
cools the early Earth is steeped in the
building blocks for
life but putting them together still
seems to require a
miracle or does
it